you think the pizza should stay a dollar
yeah stay a dollar
[Music]
dollar1 the dollar slice is a certified
New York City icon for more than a
decade 99 Cent pieas have been feeding
the masses here in the five burrows
serving hot slices to everyone from
businessmen to broke college kids but is
the Golden Age of the dollar slice
finally over in the last year shops that
Once Sold slices for just a buck have
been raising their prices to $150 and
you know New Yorkers have something to
say about it today I'm on a mission to
better understand the current state of
the dollar slice in NYC I want to hear
directly from the shop owners and peace
of loving New Yorkers who survive off
the slice day in and day out first I'm
meeting up with two Bros owners Ellie
and Orin halali to see how things are
changing for one of the most
recognizable names in the dollar slice
game
you can't talk about the dollar slice
without talking about t Bros how did you
guys start selling dollar slices here in
New York city so we were both in college
and we we we both love pizza growing up
and we said let's open a pizzeria it was
ready to open and we're like we got to
do some marketing how we going to Market
this thing how are we going to get
customers we put out an A-frame on the
street and we just wrote with a marker
on a big chalkboard $1 pizza right and
nothing was really happening right
ultimately we ended up ordering one of
these signs you know red and black and
white and it just said Pizza a dollar
and from that day on it was like history
right tell us more about why did that
have to change like why did you have to
go from a dollar to the a150 slice what
happened well we held firm for 15 years
right we opened our first store in uh uh
towards the end of 2007 uh the last 3 4
years were incredibly challenging
especially the last 2 years with
inflation every single item that we have
to buy for our cogs went up
significantly and one thing we never
wanted to do was was cut the quality
that's why we decided to raise the price
because the New Yorkers are the smartest
people in the world you're not going to
trick them especially not twice so EXA
our products always been very very high
level for the price you're never going
to get a better deal you're not going to
fool any New Yorker they you know they
could go to this place and they can go
to the other guy selling for a dollar or
the other guy selling for $2 they can
eat it they can understand it and they
can know they're getting value here for
their
money so how have your customers reacted
to the change I think for the most part
it's been positive you got to keep in
mind that right now we're selling two
two cheese slices of pizza and a drink
for $4 you can't get a meal at
McDonald's for for for under $10 right
so so we're still you know the cheapest
and uh I think people appreciate that
we've waited this long and and we tried
everything in our power to really keep
the price where it was you guys got your
start selling dollar slices but you're
thinking bigger than that tell us a
little bit more about upside Pizza I
think one thing the dollar slice did in
New York it it made the mediocre three
to4 slice obsolete right one one thing
we realized during that period though is
that the Elevated Places had a
Renaissance we created this unbelievably
efficient business you know we dominated
this field we partnered with you know
one of our close friends no I'm grman
who runs the company we said why can't
we do the same thing making the best SCE
in New York right and that's what we
tried to do with upside well you know I
can't leave without getting a good
oldfashioned $150
slice I love it hits the spot brings me
right back to my party days from Miami
for $150 you can't beat it you can't
beat it it's amazing say realistic guts
right
there a 50 Cent price hike may not seem
like a big deal but it can have a
serious impact on a slice Shop's bottom
line for Ellie and Armen the change has
allowed Tu Bros to weather the storm of
inflation without sacrificing the
quality of its product but I want to
hear what customers think of the rising
cost of pizza near Washington Square
Park I found a shop that still offers
true 99 cent slices and ask New Yorkers
if they could tell tell the difference
between Dollar Pizza and $3
Pizza what's your name my name is kadus
first things first what's today's
mathematics
pizza that's what we do we doing Pizza
I'm from the Bronx New York 222nd in
White Plains Road baby 1961 I was born
there John Gotti ran my neighborhood yo
we love John Gotti we eat pizza This Is
How We Do We fold we put our finger in
there we are
out so we have two slices of to there
can you tell the difference between the
dollar slice and the $3 slice yeah the
the $3 slice got that you a even
try it I don't got to it got the
dripping up look got to be splashy this
one they just threw it in there pink po
this one right here is a dollar one but
what did you tell about I don't know the
color of the crust the consistency
immediately off back there's less cheese
on a dollar slice which is this one the
$3 slice got more top end the quality is
better you can hear a crunch can you
tell the difference between a dollar
slice and a $3 slice first the color if
this was a person they would be
baldheaded completely white no 10 and
probably ready to vomit on you look at
it all right I'm not trying to say
nothing but it ain't
[Music]
healthy it tastes
good what do you think about the dollar
slice being raised to $150 that's some
it's some I don't know
I feel like and certain things you
should keep New York so we got standard
clown standard clown have you in a
dollar s so down the block is a slice it
was $2 for a beverage and a nice slice
of pizza but now it's like $3 and I am
that that extra dollar goes a long way
the slice isn't changing the slice isn't
changing no matter what like they're
dragging up the price the slice ain't
changing what do you think about the
rising cost of pizza you think the pizza
should stay a dollar stay a dollar stay
a dollar dollar
$1o what do you feel about the dollar
slice now being increased to $150 I
think it's kind of ass hey
I can take these of
course growing up the dollar s always
been essential but it's about the
quality so now that everybody's trying
to like boost their prices the dollar
slice quality went down my bad days I'm
down bad I'm getting this dollar slice
my good days I'm getting this this slice
right here you
know the dollar slice is a uniquely New
York phenomenon and the people who live
here feel strongly about it but besides
the price on the menu what actually
makes a dollar slice a dollar slice and
where did this thing even come from I
know someone who should have all the
answers I'm looking for hey I'm Scott
weiner founder of Scott's Pizza tours
and I'm here to tell you everything I
know about Dollar Pizza dollar slices
are always very light on tomato sauce so
you can hold it up and the slice will
always pass the vertical hang test
really cheese aderes you can see
evidence that it's a screen baked pie so
this is not going to be a brick oven
pizza you're not going to see Scorch
marks on the bottom or Char also on the
edge I always notice there there's a
density to the crumb so the crumb
structure of a longer fermentation dough
it's going to be much more open a
shorter fermentation dough like a dollar
slice is going to be close and a little
bit more dense a little bit more
spongy first thing it hits you when
you're having a dollar slice is Herb so
this is not just a San Marzano tomato
sauce or anything like that tomato
oregano garlic onion powder you taste
more of the additives to the tomato
sauce than just the Tomato itself next
thing that you get is the mozzarella
it's a salty mozzarella and then finally
it's a textural thing you won't get a
snap it's really more of a squish Factor
as you bite all the way
through that is right down the center of
the lane a dollar
slice history of the dollar size pizza
in New York City did cost a dollar in
the mid1 1980s and then after that
things took off okay we did not have a
dollar slice in New York City again
until the early 2000s the first place I
know that was doing it was 99 cent fresh
pizza which was right across the street
from the port authority on 9th Avenue
and then there was nothing else until
about 20 8 after the economic downturn
we started to see a lot more dollar
slice shops open and the idea was if you
can maintain foot traffic and you can
sell high volume then you can sell a
slice of pizza for a dollar the thing
about the dollar slice is that the
moment it started it knew that it had a
limit so if the cost of Labor goes up if
rent goes up or if your cost of goods
sold flower your cheese your tomato if
they go up that rattles the whole
business model so the Golden Age of the
dollar slice
is ending I just hope we all enjoyed it
what we
did for some selling pizza for just a
buck started as a smart business plan
for others the dollar slice actually
began as a student special and a way to
give back to their communities hockey
akenz is the owner of the local chain
Champion Pizza a Turkish immigrant
hockey moved to New York City in 2001
with just over $200 in his pocket hockey
went on to become a world champion do
tosser wowing judges by spinning flaming
does above his head today inflation has
forced Champion Pizza to raise its
prices like everyone else but hocky
continues to offer a $150 slice to
students and gives free pizza to anyone
who can't afford a meal I'm meeting up
with hockey to better understand how he
sees affordable Pizza as a Force for
[Music]
good so hockey your story is amazing
tell us how you went from staying at the
B mission to owning a chain of pizzas in
the city I came over here in 2001 uh
when I came over here with a big dream
and I have a friend he you know he told
me Hy if you come New York City I will
help you with job and I will help you
with a place that you could stay and
when I came over here I call him he make
me wait at the Port Authority for 2 and
1 half days I have $240 in my pocket so
sleeping all the street and I met one
guy from Sagal his name Ronnie he helped
me and he told me there's a place up a b
Mission everything free I there was a
hotel he said as a homeless shelter but
I don't know what to mean homeless
shelter next time I was every day going
pizza shops you know like restaurants
looking for jobs I woke up as dishwasher
about 4 months and U one day the pizza
man didn't came I guess he was drunk he
didn't show up it was weekend I say no
like you don't have to raise me just
give me say money I just want to make I
want to be pizza man I don't want to be
dishwasher anymore the first paycheck
they gave me $300 it changed my
life when you first started you were
selling pizza for a dollar slice right
actually was not Dollar Store I was at
like $250 I did like a Dollar Pizza for
all the students why is it so important
to keep Pizza affordable there's a
school around me right my neighbor like
three kids when they come two of them
they was eating pizza and the third one
they was look at them so I know this
person doesn't have money and even like
I asked a couple time you know like why
you don't want to get slic you know
hungry oh I don't have money on me so I
was giv them slice GI you know drink and
I say you know what I need to do make a
spish maybe student spal from like uh
10:00 a.m. to 3:00 p.m. and later on you
know like kids they bring their parents
oh yes so now they want to get a price
so I say you know what let's just keep a
dollar and I did for dollar for about
like 10 years wow but this Co it
destroys man like you know everything go
like triple and triple the pizza boxes I
used to get for like uh $15 today I pay
$45 wow pepperoni I used to buy like $40
right now I pay like $120 how much is a
slice now the cheese slice over there
for the kids still 150 oh that's still
good yeah yeah that's wonderful but if
you don't have money you can't go get a
free pizza oh you can get free P oh yeah
you guys can try any store you go you
say I don't have money we'll get free
pizza so hockey I've always wanted to
work on my dough tossing skills will you
help me let's make a let's go let's go
yeah
[Music]
yeah you know how you shoot the
basketball how you shoot basketball
twist yes yes do like that first yes yes
yes perfect yeah yeah now we do two
hands
yes oh I see okay
okay you doing really good you do really
good you doing really good you doing
really good this is great I'm having fun
so now let's do bicycle bicycle so we do
it like this way oh look at that I'm
going to go home and practice look at
that there a bicycle okay okay now I'm
going to get umbrella for you umbrella
okay oh you see them slowly slowly yes
what Nico before you leave the slice
that we give a kids for $150 you want to
try of
[Music]
course
m m so good oh my
god get your mind the pizza I had as a
kid oh really yeah yes and the kids are
so lucky to have you keep up the great
work and we love you hockey thank you so
[Music]
much whether you sell it for a dollar or
$150 the slice is still the food of the
people in New York City access to
affordable quality Pizza can feel like a
human right to New Yorkers but the
neighborhood sliced joints that feed
them have been forced to raise their
prices or else face Extinction for a
shop owner like hockey raising prices
has allowed his business to stay afloat
so he can continue to offer cheap and
even free pizza to the people who need
it most the beauty of the dollar slice
is that it originally existed as a
community service that 99 cent fresh
pizza at the Port Authority that place
existed next to a shelter and and it
opened pretty much to serve people using
that shelter that dollar slice really is
a part of the community and does a
community service by making available
food for a low budget and that's why
people like hakak Dennis he does this
for a reason the other slices cost more
but he cares about the community I learn
for my mom back in the days you know
like when he have something if you can
share just share it okay when someone
need you help just help them right away
no one become poor when you give him
back exactly you cannot compete with God
you know like you give one he give you
two you give two he give you four you
give you four he give you eight but
sometime he give you triple me I get
Triple oh my God God love me so much you
know like all you need to to have a go
[Music]
[Applause]
hard
w